>> IT'S THANKSGIVING.
AND IT WOULDN'T BE THE HOLIDAYS
WITHOUT HEINZ.
>> HONEY, COULD YOU PASS THE
KETCHUP?
>> WELL, I'M JUST HAPPY THAT
WE'RE ALL TOGETHER FOR
THANKSGIVING.
[ FART NOISE ]
>> WHOA, EASY THERE, GREG.
>> THAT WASN'T ME.
IT WAS THE KETCHUP BOTTLE.
>> ARE YOU SURE ABOUT THAT, DAD?
>> YEAH, I'M VERY SURE.
I DIDN'T CUT A FART AT
THANKSGIVING DINNER.
I WOULDN'T DO THAT.
IT'S NOT WHO I AM.
>> YEAH, DAD, WE KNOW.
>> IT HAPPENS EVERY YEAR.
THE KETCHUP BOTTLE MAKES AN
INNOCENT NOISE AND EVERYONE
THINKS YOU RIPPED ONE AT THE
DINNER TABLE.
THEY SAY THEY BELIEVE YOU, BUT
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY'RE THINKING.
IT'S MADE EVERY THANKSGIVING A
LIVING HELL.
UNTIL NOW.
INTRODUCING HEINZ RELAX.
THE KETCHUP YOU KNOW AND LOVE
WITHOUT THE UNCOMFORTABLE NOISE.
NOW WHEN YOU SQUEEZE THE BOTTLE,
IT SIMPLY LETS OUT A RELAXING
SIGH.
SO THIS THANKSGIVING, THINGS
WILL BE DIFFERENT.
>> HONEY, CAN YOU PASS THE
KETCHUP?
>> SURE.
>> CAN I SAY I AM SO GRATEFUL TO
BE HERE --
[ MOANING ]
>> WHAT WAS THAT?
>> THAT WAS THE SOOTHING SOUND
OF HEINZ RELAX.
LOOKS LIKE THIS BOTTLE'S ALMOST
EMPTY.
[ MOANING ]
>> THAT SOUNDS LIKE --
>> A RELAXED SIGH.
I KNOW.
>> THAT AIN'T WHAT THAT SOUNDS
LIKE.
>> HEY, EVERYONE JUST -- RELAX.
[ INTENSE MOANING ]
>> SPARE YOURSELF FROM FURTHER
EMBARRASSMENT WITH OUR WHOLE
FAMILY OF HEINZ RELAX PRODUCTS.
GLASS BOTTLES.
[ GROANING ]
MUSTARD.
EVEN MAYO.
>> OHH!
>> MOM, CAN I BE EXCUSED?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WAIT, WHERE ARE YOU GOING WITH
THAT?
>> MY ROOM?
>> NO.
PUT THAT DOWN.
>> THE BOY LOVES KETCHUP, JUST
LIKE HIS OWN MAN.
>> HEINZ RELAX.
NOW AVAILABLE AT YOUR LOCAL
SUPERMARKET.
MUST BE 18 OR OLDER TO BUY.